- So wait, you and Nick have a ritual
that I didn't know about.
So it's called show and tell.
This is pretty cute.
Explain-
- It kind of isn't a ritual,
it just happened because of necessity.
We both didn't know very much
about each other's careers.
I mean, I know of the Jonas Brothers,
but you know, it's a different generation.
- Yeah.
- I was like, I didn't
really grow up with the music
and so I didn't know the history,
even though him and I
both have 22 year careers,
'cause he started his at seven.
- Yeah.
- But so we started showing
each other each other's work.
Like, we would sit and
be like, "Oh, you know,
this was the most traumatic day
on set for me when my first movie."
And he was like, "Oh this
was my most traumatic show."
And we'd kind of show
each other our careers
or highlights from our careers
and talk about what we were
really feeling that time.
And it's just become this
thing that we do whenever-
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- We're by ourselves at home.
We just go down the rabbit hole.
- Because y'all met and y'all got together
pretty quickly, right?
- Yeah.
So it's kind of cool, you get
to know each other like still.
- Yeah, I mean, we knew each
other for about two years.
- Yeah.
- But we didn't like really date.
We were both in other things.
- Like other jobs and stuff, yeah?
- No, other relationships.
- Oh, other relationships.
Oh yeah.
Totally.
Thought you meant jobs.
- I was trying to be subtle.
- We both weren't sure.
I think that's awesome though.
Like to show like...
I don't know, I just
think it's a very cute way
to like get to know your significant other
that you think you know everything about.
But they weren't there
for that whole time.
- They weren't, right.
And I think it's such a fun thing to...
Especially both of us have
had such public careers.
We've both grown up in our own way.
- I love that you both didn't know
each other's careers either.
- I know, it's so crazy.
- That's kind of cool.
- I think so too.
It's really fun.
Like, you know-
- [Kelly] You're there
for the right reasons.
- And we show each other
our embarrassing moments
'cause you know, that's your person
and you're safe with them.
- Yeah.
And it's funny.
- I show him my bad performances
and be able to laugh at it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Oh, me too, I have plenty.